[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur elite gibt ein
kleines fünf minuten rezept und war
machte es fünf minuten braucht also im
kontext sehen sie aus wie brownies aber
haben eigentlich nicht braun ist nichts
zu tun denn diese teile hier die werte
nicht gebacken von cool der
energielieferanten denn ich habe hier
kaffee mit drin als süßes oder als
natürliche süßungsmittel hab ich ihr
doppel mit dabei waren mitte und mandeln
und ein bisschen espresso schwindlig
super lecker und vor allem schnell
zubereitet ich find's ganz gut 1 nächste
zwischendurch oder auch mal zum
mitnehmen
man kann sie nämlich hier so wie ich als
beilage zubereiten oder auch als kleine
bällchen formen ja so oder so richtig
aus dem sechseinhalb millionen ja
wahrscheinlich gesicht immer so
da kommt man da nicht klar damit aber
wasser und paul savary auch genau man
kann das ganze auch für feiern und sagen
ich möchte ein espresso damit man im
saft oder man nimmt noch cranberries mit
rein also wirklich da gibt es ganz ganz
viele möglichkeiten was man damit noch
anstellen kann genau richtig cool ich
hatte ja schon mal gemacht und war
damals schon sehr aktiv
die ganze schule gehen und wird diese
energie auch brauchen ja ich bin ja so
einen teuren parkplatz aber nicht gehört
zum glück und deswegen gehe ich direkt
weiter bei den zutaten und stellt ihr
euch hier vorne vor an zutaten brauchen
250 gramm entscheidende doppel 120 120
von mandeln 50 gramm kakaopulver zwei s3
so die demo etwas von ihr extrakt und
eine prise salz
das nämlich jetzt geht das und der
preistrend stein
die kommen hier reinbringen dass durch
die füße mit rein und da geht es besser
drauf ist dann ein bild in manila
extrakt können wir natürlich weglassen
aber vanille ist einfach mit dazu und
die zutaten werden jetzt kurz ge mit
einem ass und da kommen jetzt noch die
nutzer mit rein und auch gemeinden
kakaopulver
das salz und jetzt wird noch mal alles
gimmicks sein dass er ab und zu mal
reingucken wird und die sachen so ein
bisschen vom rand nach unten drückt
damit sich wirklich alles schön
verbindet die masse sind fertig bei mir
sind jetzt müsse noch ein bisschen krupp
ich habe hier aber auch gerne so wenn
ihr gerne eine ganz homogene masse
möchtet könnt ihr so erst einmal die
weite und die mandeln ein bisschen
verkleinern und dann mit dem
restaurieren
ich habe das ganze jetzt auf meine dauer
back folie drauf denn wie kann ich jetzt
hier zu klappen denn wirklich verklebt
und kann damit jetzt dan brown forman
minuten aufbaustab oder ihr könnt auch
ein schneidebrett nehmen und einfach ein
bisschen drüber halten und zu bitten
flach drücken dass volkswagen verhandeln
kann man das ganze den für den
kühlschrank stellen so wird auch noch
mal ein bisschen fester und später
gibt's einfach nur noch zurecht
geschnitten
das heißt er wirklich nur maximal fünf
minuten vorbereitungszeit und dann
einfach mal aussehen beträgt minuten
wartezeit im kühlschrank und dann haben
wir gleich unsere gesünderen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier die braune masse
sie steht jetzt auch nicht mehr so sehr
wie am anfang aber trotzdem immer noch
klebrig ihr könnt ihr zu lassen ihr
könnt auch mit cacau bestreuen das aber
nicht schlampig herbst oder ihr könnt
auch bäcker steigen
das ist eine reine kartoffelstärke und
dann klappt es vielleicht auch nicht so
sehr am messer und es gab so auf ein
schneidebrett jetzt kann ich daraus
wirklich schneiden
ihr könnt aber auch die masse nehmen und
zum beispiel kugeln formen also das kann
natürlich auch machen aber damit sehr
aussehen wie brownies finde ich sollte
man sie in würfel oder einfach in
rechtecke schneiden
[Musik]
das passe doch das waren in fünf minuten
brownie aus richtig gesungen zutaten
eine gesündere kuranyi gehört bin ich
glücklich nicht weil gesündere brown ist
ohne zucker dafür die dattel mit dabei
war süße mandeln espresso also richtig
quelle keinen raffinierter zucker
energielieferant und genau wie probieren
ich bin ja so viel energie ja auf jeden
fall bin laden gewesen mehr hilfen
knochen und powerriegel genau
powerriegel und jankulovski de kann man
auch nicht zu arbeiten oder im büro
wie gesagt als kugel formen oder auch so
wie hier also paradoxon dass ihr das
rezept nach machen wollt könnt ihr gerne
auf meinem blog vorbeischauen auffällig
- blog.de da steht noch mal alles ganz
genau und ich wünsche euch ganz nicht
nachmachen und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
für freunde kein problem